물론 이 모든 것은 다음 강의에서 볼
Shor 알고리즘으로 이어지고 있어요. 이건 소인수분해를 위한 효율적인 양자 알고리즘이에요.
하지만 거기에 도달하기 전에 아직
다뤄야 할 내용이 좀 있어요.
다음으로 다양한 알고리즘의
계산 비용을 측정할 수 있는 수학적 프레임워크에 대해 이야기할 거예요.
이미 이야기한 것들도 포함해서요.
분명히 말하면, circuit에 아주 좁게 초점을 맞출 거예요.
이건 훨씬 더 넓은 주제의 작은 부분에 불과해요.
지난 강의에서의 일반적인 계산에 대한 매우 높은 수준의 관점부터 시작해 볼게요.
특히 질의 문제를 생각하는 게 아니라
입력이 이진 문자열로
명시적으로 주어지는 문제를 생각하는 거예요.
지난 강의에서 말했듯이, 원한다면 다른 기호를
허용할 수도 있지만, 간단하게 이진 문자열을 고수할게요.
입력과 출력 모두에 대해서요.
계산 자체는 튜링 머신 계산 모델 같은
다양한 방식으로 모델링하거나 설명할 수 있어요.
Boolean circuit, quantum circuit, 또는 Python이나
다른 언어로 작성된 프로그램으로요.
방금 말했듯이, Boolean과 quantum
circuit에 초점을 맞출 거예요.
먼저, 이진 문자열이라고 가정하는 입력과 출력에 대해 좀 더 시간을 들여 이야기해 볼게요.
이진 문자열을 사용하면, 숫자, 벡터,
행렬, 그래프 같은 많은 종류의
수학적 객체를 인코딩할 수 있어요.
예를 들어 분자의 설명이라든지, 이 모든 객체들의 목록과 다른 것들도요.
아주 간단한 예로, 비음수 정수를
이진 문자열로 인코딩하려면 이진 표기법을 사용하면 돼요.
이 표에서 처음 13개의 비음수 정수와 함께
그 이진 표현 또는 인코딩을 볼 수 있어요.
여기 세 번째 열에서 각 인코딩의 길이를 볼 수 있는데,
이건 인코딩에 필요한 총 비트 수예요.
그리고 여기에 임의의 비음수 정수 N에 대해 일반적으로
몇 비트가 필요한지 정확히 알려주는 간단한 공식이 있어요.
특히 인코딩의 길이가 일반적으로
숫자 자체보다 훨씬 작다는 점에 주목하세요.
숫자에 대해 로그적이에요.
예를 들어 RSA1024는 길이 1,024의 인코딩을 가지지만,
숫자 자체는 물론 그보다 훨씬 커요.
이 인코딩 방식은 비음수 정수에 대해서 작동하지만,
음수를 포함한 임의의 정수를 다루고 싶으면
부호 비트를 추가하면 돼요.
인코딩이 고정 크기의 비트 블록이나 레지스터를 채우도록
하고 싶으면 선행 0을 얼마든지 허용할 수도 있어요.
충분히 크기만 하면요. 때로는 그게 아주 편리해요.
이건 정수를 비트 문자열로 인코딩하는 유일한 방법은 아니에요.
다른 방법들도 있지만, 이건
꽤 표준적인 방법이에요.
우리가 관심 있는 계산 문제의 입력이나 출력을 형성할 수 있는
다른 종류의 객체에 대해서도 다른 인코딩 방식을 만들 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 벡터나 그래프를
이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 방법을 생각해 보거나
두 개의 이진 문자열을 공백이나 다른 기호 없이
0과 1만 사용해서 하나의 이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 방법을 생각해 보세요.
이런 것들을 하는 방법은 분명히 있고,
사실 정확히 어떻게 하는지에 대해 많은 자유가 있어요.
종종 우리가 말하는 것을 이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 단 하나의 표준적이거나
보편적으로 합의된 방법은 없을 거예요.
하지만 괜찮아요. 하나를 고르거나 원하면 새로운 걸 만들면 돼요.
순수하게 형식적인 관점에서, 우리는 계산을 본질적으로 비트 문자열에 대한 기계적 변환으로 생각해요.
우리가 사용하는 인코딩 방식의
세부사항은 어느 정도 수준에서는 확실히 중요해요.
하지만 그럼에도 불구하고, 알고리즘을 설계하고
분석할 때, 인코딩 방식의 세부사항에 대해 보통 그렇게 많이 걱정하지 않아요.
두 명의 다른 사람에게 특정 유형의 분자를
이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 방법을 만들어 달라고 하면
다른 방법을 제안할 수 있겠지만, 자기가 뭘 하는지 아는 합리적인 사람들이라면
두 인코딩 방식 사이를 변환하는 것이 꽤 간단한
계산 과정이 될 거라고 합리적으로 기대할 수 있어요.
아마 우리가 실제로 관심 있는 계산에 비하면
매우 간단한 계산이 될 거예요.
결론은 우리가 사용하는 인코딩 방식에 관한 세부사항은 종종 꽤 부차적이고 우리의 초점은
알고리즘 자체에 있다는 거예요.
이번 강의에서는 이게 문제가 되지 않을 거예요. 이진으로 인코딩된다고 가정하는 정수에 관한 문제에 주로 초점을 맞출 거지만,
알아두면 좋은 내용이에요.
일반적으로, 어떤 종류의 문제를 다루든, 입력 길이는
입력을 인코딩하는 데 필요한 비트 수를 의미해요.
그리고 입력 길이를 우리가 생각하는 문제의 인스턴스 크기로 봐요.
이제, 이 그림에서 파란색 직사각형으로
표현된 계산 자체를 살펴볼게요.
이 계산의 비용을 측정하는 방법은
필요한 기본 연산의 수를 세는 거예요.
직관적으로 말하면, 기본 연산은 작고 고정된
수의 비트나 qubit에 관한 연산이에요.
예를 들어 두 비트의 AND를 계산하는 것처럼
빠르고 쉽게 수행할 수 있는 연산이요.